[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu tort je suis revenue dans cette
ville au loin perdue où j'avais passé
mon
enfance j'ai eu tort j'ai voulu revoir
le qu glissé le soir bleu et gris ombre
de silence et j'ai retrouvé comme
avant longtemps après le côeau l'arbre
se dressant comme au passé je marche les
tempes brûlantes croyantes étouffé sous
mes fles les voies du Pass quiinouantes
et revienne son le
glam je me suis couché sous l'arbre et
c'était les mêmes odeurs j'ai laissé
couler mes
pleur
pleurs j'ai mis mon don à l'épte l'arbre
m'a redonné des forontes tout comme au
temp de mon enfance et longtemps j'ai
fermé les yeux je crois que j'ai prié un
peu je rrouver mon
innocence avant que le soir ne se pose
j'ai voulu voir la maison fleurir sous
les rose j'ai voulu voir le jardin où
nos pris d' enfant jaillissaient de
source clair g Clau de r Régine et puis
Jean tout redevenu comme hier le parfum
lourd et songur
alia fau dans laalline depuis tout j'ai
tout
retrouvé eté
[Musique]
là la guerre nous avait jeté là d'autres
furent moins heureux je crois autant
joli de leur enfance la guerre nous
avait jeté là nous vivions comme he la
loi et j'aimais cela quand j'y pense au
m Printant au MES soleil oh mes fes all
perdu oh mes 15 ans mes merveilles que
j'ai mal trop revenu oh le loix frège de
septembre et l'odeur des murs écrasés
c'est fou tout j'ai tout retrouvé
[Musique]
HL il ne faut jamais revenir autant
cacher des souvenirs du temps béni de
son
enfance car parmi tous les souvenirs ce
de l'enfance sont les pires ce de
l'enfance nous
déchire vous m'z chérie oh ma mère où
êtes-vous donc aujourd'hui vous dormez
au CHA de la terre et moi je suis venue
ici pour y retrouver votre har votre
palis et votre
jeunesse je suis seule avec ma
détresse
[Musique]
ml pourquoi suis-je donc revenu et seul
où des tours de seru j'ai froid j'ai
peur le soir se Pange
pourquoi suis-je venu ici où mon passé
me crucifie
elle donne jamais mon
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
se